This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the Outer. My Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in selling, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian. Michael Mancini.
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode, another topic, another deep dive as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Okay, there has been a trend that I've been noticing recently, both within myself, but also those around me, across social media, amongst my workmates, even from you guys, the listeners, that everybody is talking about. And that is our collective declining ability to concentrate and our ability to focus. So many of us in this day and age are struggling to stay on task, struggling to keep away from our phones and kind of push back against like the siren call of
TikTok and Instagram. One professor has even stated that our levels of inattention have reached an epidemic rate. That might sound a little bit extreme, but I think that it's something that all of us can relate to. I want you to seriously ask yourself the simple question of when was the last time you were able to spend a complete hour on a single task without getting distracted. For me, I think for most of us, we probably can't remember that time. It's pretty safe to assume that there has been a gradual decrease in our attention spans
going on for some years. A lot of us really started noticing it post-COVID and post-lockdown when a lot of us really did get quite engrossed in short form content on TikTok, when we lacked any structure to our days, when we were allowed to kind of follow any impulse that we had because there was nothing else to do. That has seemingly bled into where we are now. And the consequences of that time,
and I think a whole number of factors, is contributing to our inability to focus and concentrate for a sustained period of time. the area I think we notice it most is when it comes to those kind of activities that require us to be concentrated for some time. So I'm going to say more than an hour at least, but where there are little short-term consequences if we don't stay focused. So things like study or remote work where, yes, there are things that you need to get done, but you are in charge of your own timeline. And so you can get drawn into doom scrolling,
into Wikipedia deep dives, into TikTok, look up at the clock, realize that 30 minutes have gone by and, you know, having to kind of try and start all over again only to find yourself a few minutes later to draw them back into some other task or some other source of entertainment. I think that is the area where a lot of us are noticing this occurring. The other space is around daily planning and getting things done on a daily level. daily tasks, but also in conversations with others. I don't know if this is just something I've noticed amongst my friends that we've spoken about, but our conversations are becoming a lot more
quick and there is a lot more space and a lot more kind of like jumping around rather than like a continued sustained focus on one topic. So I asked you guys, how many of you had noticed a shift in your attention span in the last two, five years. 88% of you had noticed at least some difference in an area of your life and 60% of you noticed a huge difference within that. That was from almost 8,000 responses. So this is not like a small number. This isn't a small minority of the population.
And it shows that this impact on our ability. to focus and the impact that we're feeling on our attention spans is significantly burdening those of us in our 20s and those of us in younger generations. Think back to when we were, you know, in our early mid-teens. I remember that I could sit down and read a book for hours and the time would just fly by. I could focus on my homework for a solid chunk of time before I needed a break. I could watch TV and not kind of needs to be on my phone at the same time. I could have conversations and not be thinking about, you know, my to-do list and all the other things that I needed to get done. I think our attention spans are shrinking in very measurable and observable ways,
and it's valuable that we talk about it. So in today's episode, firstly, we're going to understand why, why is this happening? Do we only have our phones to blame? Or is it kind of a broader combination of burnout, of overstimulation, of repetitive workloads, of trying to do everything at once, and, you know, big media and marketing companies really leveraging what they know about our attention spans. But also, what is the impact? If you haven't already seen an impact for yourself, what is some of the psychology saying about what this means for us long term? And finally, is there a solution? I feel like that is quite a rhetorical question. Of course there is I wouldn't be talking about this if I didn't have something that you could do about it.
So we're going to talk about it. And I also wanted to hear from you guys. You all wrote in some incredible responses about, you know, late-stage ADHD diagnoses, which are becoming so much more common. You spoke about screen times above nine or ten hours a day, deleting apps and then redownloading them later, missed deadlines, you know, late night spent compensating for all the distractions. There were so many valuable insights that came from you all, the listeners, and I want to share it all. So without further ado, I'm going to stop rambling. And let's discuss what it is
about our attention spans these days and why it seems harder than ever to stay focused. Let's get into it. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you
about our attention spans these days and why it seems harder than ever to stay focused. Let's get into it. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2% that's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people? I know what you're thinking. What? The hell does George Bush got to do a little count? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2% that's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people? I know what you're thinking. What? The hell does George Bush got to do a little count? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line.
We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the middle health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase
that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth.
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Keer Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free, Our Heart Radio app.
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So let's quickly get up to speed on some of the basics of attention. We tend to think of attention as being only one thing, the ability to focus on one specific task for a continuous period of time without being distracted.
And it's something that's in our control. What we're talking about when we talk about a controlled, sustained period of focus is actually only one form of attention called sustained attention. We also have selective attention where there are multiple stimuli and things going on in the environment and we have to choose to focus on just one and tune in or filter out the other distractions. And then we have alternating attention. This is also known as multitasking where we switch back and forth between tasks that have different cognitive demands. So this might sound efficient, right?
You're writing your essay whilst also listening to a lecture or your teaching. texting and driving, that's the classic one. But study after study will tell you that when you're performing two or more tasks at once, especially ones that are cognitively demanding and splitting up your focus, this will actually lead to lower efficiency on both tasks. It makes us sloppier, it increases our stress, but also, I think I can speak from experience, it takes so much more time than if you just done each thing, you know, one after the other and consecutively. So that is alternating attention and the final kind of attention we have is divided attention. And this is very similar to alternating.
It basically highlights our ability to react to two or more different demands or things in our environment simultaneously. So this kind of attention, dividing attention, is just less cognitively demanding. it basically is your ability to watch TV whilst also eating. Normally the actions that we're doing are quite procedural. So of all these kinds of attention, the area where a lot of us are suffering is selective attention. Basically, our environment has a lot of stuff going on and we have to choose to only focus on one thing within that
in order to get shit done. I think most people without chronic attention issues or conditions or neurotypes like ADHD could likely focus fairly well if they were given a task in a quiet, empty room. That is where sustained attention really flourishes when we only have one thing to do, one thing to focus on, nothing else. But in a very modern world, these conditions, they are so rare. Our lives are filled to the brim with opportunities for distraction or competing
stimuli. And so we need to be able to filter all those other things out and prioritize what's in front of us. That is becoming a lot harder, leading to a greater reliance on alternating attention, switching back and forth from our phone to our computer, to our environment, to somebody talking, without limited success. Some people who are a lot more qualified than me have sought some answers and explanations to this problem of our diminishing selective and sustained attention. So there was a recent study in the UK done at King's College London and it found that about half of us adults think that our attention spans are getting shorter and that number is actually going to go up for people between the ages of 18 and 34.
66% of us in that age bracket, which I'm assuming is probably you, are noticing a change, a shift, and one that is noticeable. So there is like a common myth that has been swirling around that our attention spans are now so poor that they rival that of a goldfish. It might feel that way sometimes, but actually we're still very much winning that competition, but only by a little bit. And we know this based on a longitudinal study that is actually still going on now. So one of the leading researchers in this space, in the space of attention, is Dr. Gloria Mark, and she is a psychologist and a professor from the University of California, Irvine. Now, back in the early 2000s, whilst she was studying people's attentional rhythms, which we're
going to get back to a little bit later on, she started to notice that the people she was observing were really not doing too good at staying on track. when it came to the tasks that they were being asked to do. So she switched focus. She wanted to see how long most of us or the people that she had sampled for her studies could stay on a task or a project before moving along and whether that this was being impacted by new technologies. So at the time, it was kind of like phones but also computers.
It was really before like the social media craze. But because she started early, she was able to. to track our attention spans through these big societal shifts in our access to technology. So she started back in 2004. That's almost two decades. And what they would do at the very beginning was they would quite literally follow people around. They would shadow their participants for a day with stopwatchers. That was the best kind of technology they had available to them at the time.
And for every single activity that they did, they would record the start time and the stop time. So if you are on a screen working on a word doc, as soon as you pick up your phone to check your email, you stop doing the word doc activity and the timer for the email activity starts. As soon as you stop with your email and you go and look at TikTok, for example, the email activity stops, TikTok starts.
And they wanted to see how long people were spending on each different activity before they seemingly got bored and moved on to the next. Back in 2004, the average attention span was about two and a half minutes. Throughout the years, it's become even shorter. So around 2012, it was 75 seconds. And then in the last, you know, five, six years, that has almost halved again to where we are now, which is roughly 47 seconds. That's the average amount of time that we spend concentrating on a task before we shift focus.
And if that number seems quite impossibly small, there have been other studies that have since replicated the exact same finding within seconds. And again and again, around 47, 45 seconds is the median. If you want to test that for yourself, have a look at your phone pickup data in your settings. So I will out myself. I will go first. I looked at this earlier today. And yesterday, I picked up my phone around 235 times across a 15 hour period. That is 16 times an hour. So almost once every five minutes. Now, that's not exactly 47 seconds, but you've got to remember once every five minutes, but I'm probably spending a minute on it each time. I'm probably jumping between
different apps and then I'm coming back to the task, then I'm picking up the phone again. It is all kind of averaging out to a 40-second, you know, median amount of time that you can spend focused on one thing. I will say that this sounds alarming. A lot of researchers have noted that this is very much task-dependent. So if you are doing something really, engaging, you can really focus on that single thing for a while, compared to if you're sitting in on a task that is repetitive or unnecessary or boring, like a work meeting that you really don't feel like you need to be at, or a lecture where you're not really being given an opportunity to engage, especially if it's online, right? You're more prone to distraction in those cases because
you're not fully immersed or engaged in what you're doing. So in this way, the idea of an attention span is quite vague because I think most of us would find it hard to not wander off or seek out another form of entertainment when we're doing something that doesn't really require a lot of mental effort, right? If you're just staring at a screen for five minutes doing nothing, not really engaging your brain, of course there is going to come a time where you get bored and especially your brain gets bored and pushes you to seek out, you know, a tasty little spike of dopamine from something else in your environment. So I wanted to hear from you guys when it came to this.
For me, I'd really began to notice my declining focus back when I started full-time work, but especially when I would work from home, there was no accountability. There was no pressure of an exam or an assignment deadline at university. There was no one watching over my shoulder. And so that digital temptation of my phone was pretty easy. to fall into. This only got worse when I quit my full-time job and I started working exclusively for myself. Yes, I am, you know, super passionate about what I do and I have a lot of motivation to get stuff done. But when you are alone for eight hours a day, most days working in your house in the same environment,
there are a lot of opportunities for distraction, but it's also quite boring and understimulating to be doing the same thing. And so my brain kind of circles my environment and it circles my surroundings and it is always looking for something better to be doing that is going to feel more enjoyable. You know, I think it's a really good point to be made here, especially in our current work environments for a lot of us. You can't really sit down by yourself for eight, nine, ten hours a day, stare at a screen and not expect yourself to be distracted or, you know, believe that you could pay attention for that entire time. The human brain just doesn't work like that. So I wanted to hear from you guys and what you had to say about this.
Here is someone who articulated it quite well. Since COVID, my attention span has suffered greatly. I am such a routine person and I like to be productive. However, I somehow pick up my phone for a five minutes scroll and then an hour or two has been wasted away due to an unintentional brain-rotting death scroll. Then I feel ashamed and guilty, yet also paralyzed because I think that I've wasted the whole day and there I go, I have to start again tomorrow. That shame spiral this person mentioned is something we need to speak about,
because the more powerless and overwhelmed we feel, the more this object, our phone, controls us because it feels almost personified, right? like it's not this inanimate object. It is this thing that is staring back at us that can truly impact and influence our emotional state. And there is this constant tug of war between wanting to assert control over our phone, but feeling like it's constantly winning. And finding that we're constantly being pulled in by a notification, by a call, by a text, by an email, by just our brains, constant.
speaking out of the dopamine that we know our brain will provide. Here's another perspective that I think touches on something similar. I always need to have some reels slash videos playing in the background, or else I'll feel super bored and constantly distracted by my own thoughts that are telling me to not touch my phone. I've been trying to set 15-minute Instagram reminders, but it's not helping at all. I hate it so much.
It feels like I'm no longer living in the moment. I think that's what makes this so difficult. Again, is knowing how we want to live our lives, knowing what we could do with all that time, lamenting at how unproductive we are, and feeling powerless like our phones have kind of hijacked our previously functioning attentional systems, and no matter what we do, we cannot influence this behavioral pattern.
So I want to hear from one more person who had something to say on this as well. My attention span has been seriously impacted, ever since I graduated high school. Beginning in college, I've noticed a severe decline in my ability to focus, to pay attention, or stay motivated in school, work, family obligations, even in conversations with others, unless I am really interested in it. I've also seen an uptick in my issues with organisation, forgetfulness and procrastination, even with things that I really care about.
It's frustrated the people in my life who depend on me, or I end up having to ask them for help, like when I forget my keys for the sixth time and my roommate has to come home to let me in. That very functional impact is also something that needs to be acknowledged. It's like our brain has lost its executive functioning skills and it's kind of sabotaging us in a way. If you have a neurodevelopmental disorder like ADHD, it makes sense that you would have trouble paying attention or you would you know, struggle with your impulse control. But the global prevalence for ADHD is around 6 to 9.5%. Probably that is a lower end estimate when, you know, we start focusing on things like late stage diagnosis or the fact that there are very poor criteria for identifying women and girls,
especially women of color, people of color, and also some of the stigma towards neurodevelopmental disorders. That rate of prevalence might be a little bit higher, probably around 10%, but that doesn't really match up with the 80% of people who are experiencing this decline. Like, we can't all have ADHD, right? That would be a global phenomenon. So there must be another explanation. I will say if you do think that ADHD would provide the answers and is something that is likely that you have.
You should listen to episode 148 with Ellie Middleton. She is an ADHD and autism advocate, and she goes into this more. She talks a lot about late stage and late onset. and diagnosis when you're an adult and also some of the misconceptions. But for people without a diagnosis or who, you know, don't believe they have ADHD, there can be little explanation for why our attention spans are suffering. So I want to talk about some of the other reasons that we are struggling to focus and struggling to concentrate after this short break.
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2% that's TWO
percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What? What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on The Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me,
your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness, this month. I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth,
or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way.
还是说你当好人只是因为你害怕？兄弟，这是两种不同的动机。确实如此，这是两种不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正做一个好人。我是基尔·盖恩斯，欢迎收听我的新播客《艰难学理》，我们将在这里就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。
Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd, found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct?
打开免费的 iHeartRadio 应用。搜索 Learn the Hardway 并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的诉讼之战，旨在证明真相。你曾两次篡改某个人的这份特定检测，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing.
我篡改过一次检测。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg, the lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
格雷格，这位同性恋者，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我的大脑震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《情网》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app,
女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在 IHeart Radio 应用上收听 Love Trapped 播客，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I think when we are looking for an explanation for why our attention spans are so fucked, we need to focus on what some people see as the main culprit. Of course, it's our phones. That is often the first place that our mind goes to. Our phones and the apps that they contain provide so much temptation,
苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方。我想，当我们寻找解释为什么我们的注意力持续时间如此糟糕的原因时，我们需要关注一些人认为是罪魁祸首的东西。当然，这就是我们的手机。这通常是我们的心首先想到的地方。我们的手机以及它们包含的应用程序提供了如此多的诱惑，
but also more stimulation than we can ever really get out of our everyday lives. in everyday moments, which is quite sad. But when you think about the design of social media apps, for example, or the way that you receive notifications for texts, for calls, for messages, it is all meant to achieve one thing. It is meant to keep us hooked, keep us online, and keep us using. So, as one author put it, screens and our phones in particular present a very unique mind field of distraction because they are providing us with a constant flow of information and stimulation. At its core, social media in particular was designed to capitalize on how we think. So it's little surprise that we're really drawn to it. It's not just the fact that there are algorithms
但也带来了我们在日常生活和日常时刻中永远无法真正获得的更多刺激，这相当令人悲伤。但是，当你想到社交媒体应用程序的设计，例如，或者你接收短信、电话、消息通知的方式时，这一切都是为了实现一件事。它是为了让我们着迷，让我们保持在线，并让我们继续使用。因此，正如一位作家所说，屏幕，尤其是我们的手机，呈现出一个非常独特的干扰雷区，因为它们为我们提供了源源不断的信息和刺激。其核心在于，社交媒体尤其是为了利用我们的思维方式而设计的。因此，我们真的被它吸引也就不足为奇了。这不仅仅是因为有算法
catching our attention. We have this sense that we have to respond. We have to check. We don't want to be left out and we know that if we go to our phones for entertainment, it will provide. In the same article, it goes on to explain that human brains, we know this already, they really crave novelty, they really like excitement, but also social connection. And all of these apps that we find ourselves addicted to, essentially, provide that in a very easily accessible format. And it also provides a sense of reward. So every time you go to your phone for that dopamine hit, you know that you will find something
吸引我们的注意力。我们有一种必须回应的感觉。我们必须查看。我们不想被冷落，我们知道如果我们为了娱乐而使用手机，它就会满足我们的需求。在同一篇文章中，它继续解释说，人类的大脑，我们已经知道了这一点，它们确实渴望新鲜感，它们真的很喜欢兴奋，还有社交联系。我们发现自己沉瘾的所有这些应用程序，本质上都以非常容易访问的格式提供了这一点。它还提供了一种奖励的感觉。所以每次你为了那个多巴胺刺激而拿起手机时，你知道你会找到一些东西
that will satisfy you. You know that you will find a funny video. You know that you'll find some piece of gossip or a photo of a friend that makes you feel kind of clocked into this broader social network. So it keeps you coming back for more. The other factor and other component of this is that when you continuously give in to the temptation, which it's hard not to do, right? That's the whole point of this design.
那会让你满意。你知道你会找到一个有趣的视频。你知道你会发现一些八卦或朋友的照片，让你觉得融入了这个更广泛的社交网络。所以它让你不断回头寻找更多。另一个因素和另一个组成部分是，当你不断屈服于诱惑时，这其实很难做到，对吧？这就是整个设计的重点。
Like, they want you to stay hooked. So when you do what they have essentially instructed you and manufactured you to do and you pause a task to check your phone, your brain also has to shift gears. It has to stop what you were previously doing and move on to this new task. And this process, this kind of jumping about, that negatively affects, affects the overall speed and quality of your work in the short term. And in the long term, the more you engage in task shifting, the more your brain wants to wander off and look for that new thing, because you have somewhat conditioned it into thinking, okay, when I've spent five minutes
就像，他们希望你一直着迷。所以当你做了他们本质上指示你和制造你去做的事情，你暂停一项任务去查看你的手机时，你的大脑也不得不转换档位。它必须停止你之前正在做的事情并转向这个新任务。这个过程，这种到处跳跃的行为，会在短期内对你工作的整体速度和质量产生负面影响。从长远来看，你越是参与任务转换，你的大脑就越想走神去寻找那个新东西，因为你已经在某种程度上将它条件反射化了，认为，好吧，当我花了五分钟
on something, 10 minutes on something, I get a reward. I get to change focus. And you've become very much used to alternating your attention rather than sustaining your attention. In other words, to put it more simply, essentially what is happening here is that our brains are getting used to constant diversions and that these diversions have become habit. So that is why you don't even consciously think about it before you pick up your phone to check a message, before you pick up your phone to check social media, before you get up and go to the bathroom, even though you don't need to right? It's because this is a habit that has been kind of implanted in your brain. So even when you have a conscious intention to not do something, the procedural and automatic nature of our social media habits
在某件事上，10分钟在某件事上，我就会得到奖励。我得到了改变焦点的机会。你已经变得非常习惯交替你的注意力，而不是维持你的注意力。换句话说，说得更简单一点，这里本质上发生的事情是，大脑正在习惯持续的转移注意力，而这些转移注意力已经变成了一种习惯。这就是为什么你在拿起手机查看消息之前、在拿起手机查看社交媒体之前、在你起身去洗手间之前甚至都不用有意识地去想它，尽管你其实并不需要，对吧？这是因为这是一个已经植入你大脑的习惯。因此，甚至当你是有意识地想要不做某件事时，我们的社交媒体习惯的程序化和自动化性质，
in particular, of our reaching for distraction, all of those things, have become quite permanent and like we said, quite automatic. So let's hear from our listeners about this because somebody DM'd me and it was a really great example of how this happens. I have no attention span and I think that is largely due to short form content like TikTok. I've been desperately trying to put my phone down and increased time doing stuff I love that doesn't involve a screen. I deleted TikTok a couple of months ago, however my screen time is no better and I still find myself stuck on my phone. My uni work has suffered dramatically this last year. and I cannot for the life of me concentrate.
特别是我们对分散注意力的伸手动作，所有这些事情都已经变得相当永久，正如我们所说，相当自动化。所以让我们听听听众对这件事的看法，因为有人给我发了私信，这是一个关于这如何发生的非常棒的例子。我没有注意力持续时间，我认为这在很大程度上归因于像 TikTok 这样的短视频内容。我一直在拼命放下手机，并增加做我喜欢的不涉及屏幕的事情的时间。我在几个月前删除了 TikTok，然而我的屏幕使用时间并没有变好，我仍然发现自己被困在手机上。过去这一年，我的大学作业受到了极大的影响，
I haven't been able to finish any crochet projects, something that I love doing, and I can't finish books either. It's really frustrating, and I think my phone use is the biggest issue. I mean, right now I've been sat on it for an hour instead of getting dressed. Thank you so much for sharing.
我怎么也集中不了精神。我一直无法完成任何钩针编织项目，这是我喜欢做的事情，我也无法读完书。这真的很令人沮丧，我认为我的手机使用是最大的问题。我的意思是，我现在已经在它上面坐了一个小时，还没有穿衣服。非常感谢您的分享。
I think the other factor in this is that going to our phones for entertainment is so easy. It's like the easiest alternative. It is the path of least resistance, because it is so effortless to be immediately carried away. Whereas reading or crochet projects like this person mentioned, they take more time to get into. They really require a bit of a setup.
我认为其中的另一个因素是，去手机寻求娱乐太容易了。这就像是最简单的替代方案。这是阻力最小的路径，因为轻而易举地就能立刻被带走。而阅读或这个人提到的钩针编织项目，需要更多的时间才能进入状态。它们确实需要一点前期准备。
You know, it's so much easier to go from working on a task that requires a lot of cognitive effort like at work or at uni and going to your phone where your brain can shut down versus having to completely shift to getting into a book, getting into a plot, getting into creating something. But what's fascinating to me is that the creation of something, the pursuit of something, the engagement with something like knowledge, like fiction, like a book, or something active, like making things,
你知道，从需要大量认知努力的任务（比如在工作或大学里）转到可以让你大脑关闭的手机上，要比完全转向开始看一本书、进入一个情节、投入到创造某事中要容易得多。但对我来说迷人的是，创造某事、追求某事、与知识、小说、书本等事物进行接触，或者像制作东西这样积极的事物，
it is more fulfilling in the long term, but it just takes more effort to start. And nowadays we have an easier alternative, right? Like we can just go and look at short form videos. We can just get our hit there. So the question that I kind of want to pose in response to that is, is it that we are more distractible? Is it that our attention spans are declining and it is our fault?
从长远来看，它更有成就感，但开始时需要更多的付出。而如今我们有了更简单的替代方案，对吧？就像我们可以直接去看短视频。我们可以在那里获得我们的多巴胺。所以我想要作为回应提出的问题是，是我们更容易分心了吗？是我们注意力持续时间在下降，这全是我们的错吗？
Or is it just that the world around us is more distracting? And that big media and marketing companies and apps are just like aggressively trying to fight for our attention and therefore leveraging what they know about our brain, which is that it likes novelty and newness. and that it doesn't like uncertainty or boredom, and it is taking that information, these companies, these designers, are taking what they know about our brains
还是仅仅因为我们周围的世界更让人分心？而大型媒体、营销公司和应用程序只是在积极地争夺我们的注意力，因此利用了它们对我们大脑的了解，即它喜欢新鲜感和新奇事物，并且它不喜欢不确定性或无聊，并且这些公司、这些设计师正在获取这些信息，利用他们对我们大脑的了解
and using it to essentially hijack our motivational and attentional systems for profit. Basically, like, is it our fault? Is it our fault that this is what is happening to so many of us? Or is it just that our brains are being flooded deliberately with dopamine from our phones? is it that we are increasingly working long hours at disengaging jobs in boring offices without sunlight? Is it that we are just constantly being fed very fast and quick and efficient
并用它来为利润劫持我们的动机和注意力系统。基本上，这是我们的错吗？这发生在这么多我们身上是我们的错吗？还是仅仅是因为我们的手机正在故意用多巴胺淹没我们的大脑？是因为我们越来越多地在没有阳光的无聊办公室里做着枯燥的工作，加班时间很长吗？是因为我们不断被喂食非常快速、迅速和高效的
entertainment and few alternatives? So I want to focus on that explanation for a second. Let's kind of put our phones and let's put social media aside for a moment. I think it's gotten enough hate in this episode. I've given it enough heat. Let's look at some other elements or other explanations as to why our attention spans are failing us. Is the reason that we can't focus anymore because we are perhaps too stressed and too overwhelmed? That is another explanation. So in his book, Stolen Focus, author Joanne Hari,
娱乐而几乎没有其他选择？所以我想把注意力集中在这个解释上一会儿。让我们暂时把手机和社交媒体放在一边。我想它在这集中已经得到了足够的讨厌。我已经给它够多热度了。让我们看看其他因素或对我们的注意力持续时间正在失效的其他解释。我们再也无法集中注意力的原因是因为我们可能压力太大、不堪重负吗？这是另一种解释。因此在他的书《失去的专注》（Stolen Focus）中，作家乔安·哈里，
who you might also know from his book Lost Connections, he talks about how information overload has been creeping into our lives and impairing our ability to pay attention for some time. back in the day we spent so much more time being present we had less to navigate and to do our jobs were a lot more based on problem solving or serving they were kind of forward facing they were you know very much like solution focused like there was something very tangible a problem that was very tangible that needed to be fixed or needed to be fulfilled and we would do that they were also a lot more social and a lot more collaborative, which is another thing that we need to make note of. Nowadays, it is so much simpler, but that also means it is so much more boring. It is more boring to move something around an Excel spreadsheet, to answer emails all day without connecting.
你可能也从他的另一本书《失去的连接》（Lost Connections）中认识他，他谈到了信息过载是如何潜入我们的生活并在一段时间内损害我们的注意力集中能力的。过去，我们花更多的时间活在当下，我们需要应对和的事情更少，我们的工作更多地基于解决问题或服务，它们有点面向前台，你知道的，非常注重解决方案，有一些非常具体的东西，一个需要被修复或需要被满足的非常具体的问题，我们会去做。它们也更具社交性和协作性，这是我们需要注意的另一件事。如今，它简单得多了，但这同时也意味着它无聊得多。在Excel电子表格中移动某个东西，整天不进行连接地回复电子邮件，会更加无聊。
I think that back then it was simpler times, and now we are being asked to do so much more in a much more restrictive environment without really knowing our purpose. And our, you know, our work has become very firstly screen-based, but also repetitive, almost draining. And in an increasingly, I think, competitive and overworked generation, burnout is also pretty rampant because we are pushing ourselves to do more, to be more, in an environment and in a situation that isn't necessarily fulfilling. So I think it's no wonder that we have little band-haping.
我认为那个时候是更简单的时代，而现在我们被要求在一个更加限制的环境中做更多的事情，却并不真正知道我们的目标。而且我们的，你知道的，我们的工作首先变得非常依赖屏幕，而且还带有重复性，几乎令人筋疲力尽。在日益竞争激烈和过度劳累的一代中，倦怠也非常猖獗，因为我们在一个不一定能带来成就感环境和情况下，逼迫自己做更多、成为更多。所以我觉得我们对生活中发生的一切几乎没有什么应对能力也就不足为奇了。我们不断在吸引我们注意力的事物之间跳来跳去也就不足为奇了。由于我们被倦怠所磨损，然后当然还有过度刺激，我们不再拥有足够的心理资源来适当地控制我们的冲动或注意力。所以这是我们一直在讨论的那本书《失去的专注》的另一个组成部分，
with for everything going on in our lives. It is no wonder that we are constantly bouncing between things that grab our attention. We no longer have the mental resources to properly control our impulses or our concentration because of how worn down we are by burnout and then of course also by overstimulation. So this is another component of this book that we were talking about, stolen focus. he speaks about how our brains are just being pushed so much more environmental stimuli than ever before. And so it can't actually navigate all these things. It can't actually create a hierarchy or a list of what it needs to focus on first.
他谈到我们的大脑是如何被比以往任何时候都多的环境刺激所推动的。所以它实际上无法浏览所有这些事情。它无法真正建立它需要首先关注的层次结构或列表。你知道，我前几天在悉尼城里时想到了这一点。那里有闪烁的广告牌。有拥挤的空间、耀眼的灯光、沉重的交通。每一个商店、超市、公交车上都在播放着响亮的音乐，然后我的手机在嗡嗡作响，有太多更多需要处理的信息，其速度超出了我们大脑能够适应或进化的速度。这些要求已经超出了我们大脑进化的能力。重要的是要记住，我们的大脑在数千年的设计中就是为了存在于
You know, I think about this when I was, I thought about this when I was in the city the other day in Sydney. And there are flashing billboards. There are crowded spaces, bright lights, heavy traffic. There is like loud music playing from every single song. store in supermarkets on the bus and then my phone is buzzing, there is so much more information to process at a rate that is faster than our brain has been able to adapt or evolve to. The demands have outstripped our brain's capacity for evolution. It's important to remember that we have a brain that was designed for thousands of years to exist
自然中，存在于小群体中，用双脚感受大地，为熊觅食以解决问题，考虑生存，而不仅仅是在一天中的所有时间都专注于距离我们脸部30厘米的屏幕。因此，这种从真正更广泛地看待世界、与环境互动，转向与数字化的、非常封闭的、非常像，我不知道，就在我们脸前的东西互动的转变，是我能想到的表达它的最好方式。这种转变真的只发生在过去，如果我慷慨地说，大约50年里，而50年只是一代人的适应，然而在此之前有几千代人和数千次机会让我们的祖先进行进化
in nature, to exist in small groups, to feel the ground with our feet, to forage forbearer to problem solve, to think about survival, not just to be focused on a screen that is 30 centimeters from our face at all hours of the day. So that shift from really seeing the world more broadly engaging with the environment to engaging with something digital and very closed off and very like, I don't know, right in front of our face is like the best way I can kind of think about putting it. That shift has only really taken place in the last I would say generously like 50 years and 50 years that is only a generation of adaptation whereas there were thousands of generations and thousands of opportunities for evolution
以及在过去的时代里进行发展和适应，从而创造了我们现在拥有的大脑来适应这些新环境。所以你知道，数千年来一直以一种方式做事，然后在过去50年里突然一切都变了。当你退一步以这种方式思考时，我们的大脑根本无法根据它进化和发展要做的事情来处理我们环境中正在发生的事情。那些东西太不相似了。所以我们的注意力持续时间基本上没能跟上。我们无法集中。我们无法专注于此。这不是一个孤立的问题。这不仅仅是你或我的问题。这是一个集体性的社会问题。所以就是这样吗？我们是否就这样放任它，
and development and adaptation in our ancestors in the times that have come before that have created the brain that we have now for these new circumstances so you know thousands of years of doing things one way and then in the last 50 years suddenly everything has changed. When you zoom out and think about it in that way, our brains just genuinely cannot process what is happening in our environment based on what it was, you know, what has evolved and developed to do. Those things are too dissimilar. And so our attention span is essentially failing to keep up. We can't concentrate. We can't focus. It's not an isolated problem. It is not just a you problem or a me problem. It is a collective societal problem. So is that it? Do we kind of just leave it there and
看着我们的注意力持续时间继续下降，直到我们像金鱼一样？显然不是。我把最好的留到了最后，因为尽管头条新闻和文章让它听起来不可逆转，我们仍然可以修复我们的注意力持续时间，并扭转上述所有罪魁祸首（不仅仅是我们的手机，还有我们的环境）所造成的一些损害。所以我今天为您准备了五个实用的建议，不，它们不会是像保证充足睡眠或锻炼这样的事情，因为我想我们可能都意识到了这些。相反，我为您准备了一些实际的科学实践，如果您愿意的话，甚至可能从今天开始就可以实施。我们将从第一个开始。找到你最高效的专注时间。你会注意到的一件事是，有不同的时间点
watch our attention spans continue to decline until we are like goldfish? Obviously not. I have saved the best for last because as irreversible as the headlines and the articles make it sound, we can still fix our attention span and reverse some of the damage that is done by all of the above culprits, not just our phones, but our environment. So I have five practical tips for you today and no, they are not going to be things like get enough sleep or exercise because I think we probably are all aware of those. Instead, I have some actual scientific practices for you to implement, probably even starting today if you would like. We're going to begin with the first one. Find your peak focus times. Something that you will notice is that there are different points.
在这一天中，你比其他时候更专注。我们每个人其实都有一个特定的时期，在这个时期我们更加敏锐和专注，更容易集中注意力，因为持续的注意力是以一种有节奏的模式出现的。因此，2019年发表在《耶鲁生物学与医学杂志》上的一篇论文发现，我们的认知表现要么在上午10点到下午2点之间达到峰值，要么在下午4点到晚上10点之间达到峰值。这并不意味着你不能在这些时间之外或在你不需要的峰值专注时间之外完成事情，只是可能会更困难。而这个专注时期是由我们的昼夜节律决定的，这基本上是我们身体在一天中不同时间保持清醒和睡眠、警觉或被动的自然倾向。它基于我们的
in the day where you are just more focused than others. Each of us actually has a specific period when we are more attuned and focused and it's easier to concentrate because sustained attention occurs in a rhythmic pattern. So there was a paper published in 2019 in the Yale Journal of Biology and Medicine and it found that our cognitive performance either peaks between 10 a.m. and 2 p.m. or 4 p.m. 10 p.m. That doesn't mean that you can't still get things done outside of those times or in a time that doesn't necessarily align with your peak focus time, just that it might be harder. And this focus period is determined by our chronotypes, which is basically our body's natural inclination to be awake and asleep and alert or passive at different times during the day. And it is based on our
昼夜节律。简单来说，我们的身体是在一种有节奏的规模上运作的。它在一个警觉性和某种程度上的困倦（我想这是它的反义词）的循环中工作。我们有些人是早起鸟，有些人则在太阳下山后的夜间工作得非常好。这一切都取决于你的昼夜节律是如何设置的。所以绝对我是后者。我可以在夜间集中注意力更长时间，
circadian rhythm. Put simply, our body works on a rhythmic kind of scale. It works on a cycle of alertness and kind of sleepiness, I guess, is the opposite of that. Some of us are early birds and some of us work really well during the night when the sun is down. And that all depends on how your circadian rhythm is set up. So I am definitely the latter. I can concentrate for much longer at nighttime. and I have found that that makes me a lot more productive.
我发现这让我效率高得多。与其强迫自己在一大早去做那些令人难以置信的、认知上让人不知所措且精神上费力的任务，我把它们留到下午5点之后或者至少下午2点之后，因为我知道在9点到12点之间的这段时间里，我需要做一些比较被动、需要比较少的事情，因为它们只是更容易，而且我在那些时候没那么警觉。不过对有些人来说，我有一个朋友在早上5点到10点之间工作得非常好。关键是找到适合你的方法。如果你想支持你的注意力集中能力，试着去识别和注意什么时候你感觉自己最不费力地处于心流状态。所以心流状态是一种精神状态，在这种状态下，我们完全专注于单一的任务或活动，完全沉浸其中。我们既感到充满活力，同时也享受这个过程。所以这就好像是那些例子之一，当你看着时钟，
Instead of trying to force myself to do like incredibly like cognitively overwhelming and like mentally strenuous tasks like first thing in the morning, I save them for after like 5pm or like at least after 2pm because I know that between the hours of like 9 and 12 that is the time when I need to do things that are a little bit more passive and that require a little bit less. effort because they're just easier and I'm not as alert during those times. For some people, though, I have a friend who works really well between like 5am and 10 a.m. It's about finding what works for you. And if you want to support your ability to concentrate, try and recognize and notice when it feels like you are most in a flow state without trying. So a flow state is a mental state in which we are completely focused in on a single task or activity and fully immersed. We feel both energized, but we're also enjoying the process. So that is like one of those examples of when you're just, you look up at the clock,
你意识到你已经在你的论文上工作了半个小时左右，或者你已经在一个Excel幻灯片或PowerPoint幻灯片上修修补补了一个小时，你甚至都没有意识到，你一直在编辑什么东西，你一直在和某人说话在那段时间里，时间过得超级快，因为你太专注了，你专注背后的原因可能既是因为你参与其中，但最有可能的是你也在一个你更能集中的时间进行这项活动，所以试着找到那些时间并在那个时期执行那些繁重的任务，这真的把我的带到了下一个建议：选择你的高专注任务
you realize that you've been working on your paper for like half an hour, or you've been fixing up an Excel deck or a PowerPoint deck for, you know, an hour and you haven't even realized, you've been editing something, you've been talking to somebody for that period of time and time is just going by super quickly because you are so focused and the reason behind your focus is both probably that you're engaged but most like you're also conducting this activity at a time when you are better able to concentrate so try and find those times and perform those heavy duty tasks during that period this really brings me to my next tip choose your high focus task
专注于它们，但当你完成它们时，就停下来。不要试图在精力不济的窗口期之外继续强迫自己做事，当你真正感觉到自己想要休息、想要玩手机时。这听起来可能有点反直觉，但通过为那些你视为不好的活动腾出空间、为分心腾出空间、为刷屏腾出空间无论它可能是什么，来帮助自己。我认为我们常常陷入一种恐慌，觉得自己无法集中注意力，我们走向极端，试图完全切断那些诱惑，切断我们内心想要那种分心的部分，而实际上这是过程的一部分。你的大脑最终需要从你正在做的事情中休息一下。你无法长时间维持选择性注意力甚至是集中注意力。
focus on them, but when you're done with them, stop. Don't try and keep forcing yourself to do things out of a productive window when you're really feeling yourself like wanting to take a break, wanting to go on your phone. It might sound counterintuitive, but help yourself by giving space to those activities that you see as bad, giving space to distraction, giving space to some doom scrolling, whatever it may be. I think we often get into a little bit of a panic that we can't focus, and we go to an extreme and we try and completely shut off those temptations, shut off that part of us that wants that distraction when actually it is part of the process. Your brain will eventually need a break from what you're doing. You cannot sustain selective attention or even focused attention for that long.
在某个特定的点，你将达到极限，你确实需要为你的大脑提供一些释放和解脱。所以实际上你让自己有机会做那些事情，而不是把它们高高挂起或把它们妖魔化得超过它们需要的程度，从而赋予它们很多控制你的力量。你实际上是在掌控自己的行为。所以你要允许自己留出分心的时刻。通过记住我们的注意力是以目标为导向的和目标驱动的，来提示注意力也是很有价值的。如果我们经常被提醒我们试图实现的是什么，我们就更能专注于任务。如果这个任务只是一些毫无意义的事情，如果我们看不到结果，如果我们没有被提醒原因，我们做事背后的原因，我们当然不会
There is a certain point where you will max out and you do need to provide your brain with some release and some relief. So actually you let yourself have opportunities to do those things instead of kind of putting them on a pedestal or making them taboo or villainizing them more than they need to and therefore giving them a lot of the power to control you. You are actually in control of your behavior. So you're going to give yourself permission to allow for points. of distraction. It's also valuable to cue attention by remembering that our attention is goal orientated and it's goal directed. We are better at staying on task if we are regularly reminded of what it is that we're trying to achieve. If this task is just something that's pointless, if we don't see the outcome, if we aren't reminded of why, the why behind what we're doing, of course we're not
在乎它。当然，集中注意力会变得更难。当然，我们会想要做那些更令人兴奋、更有趣并给我们带来更多多巴胺的事情。为了抵消这一点，你能做的就是在便条纸上写下你的目标，并把它放在你能看到的地方，以帮助你保持专注。在你着手做一件大事之前，比如开始一篇长篇论文、开始一个巨大的作业、一个巨大的工作项目、一个巨大的房屋清洁，给自己三个你想做这件事的原因以及完成后会有什么感觉的理由，
going to care about it. Of course it's going to be harder to concentrate. Of course we're going to want to do the thing that is more exciting and more fun and gives us more dopamine. So to counteract that, what you can do is write out your goal on a poster note and place it where you can see it to kind of help you stay focused. Before you set out to do something big, like start on a huge essay, start on a huge assignment, a huge work project, a huge house clean, provide yourself with three reasons why you want to do this thing and how it's going to feel when you're done. and two things that you're going to give yourself when you're finished.
以及当你完成时你要给自己的两样东西。所以不要只想着，天哪，这太艰难了，这太难了，我太累了，有那么多我更愿意做的事。真正激活你内心感到目标导向的那部分，并且知道当这个任务完成时它会感到满足。好的，我有四个最后的建议，专门围绕控制社交媒体的使用，因为正如我们所讨论的，正如你们很多人写信的那样，这似乎是我们最大的问题。当然，它们的设计就是为了让你上瘾。它在布局中。它在社交媒体应用程序和数字技术的架构中。但我们实际上可以抵消他们一直在利用的策略
So instead of thinking just about, oh my God, this is so rough, this is so hard, I'm so exhausted there's so much I would rather be doing. Really activate that part of yourself that feels goal directed and that knows it's going to be satisfied when this task is complete. Okay, so I have four final tips for you that are specifically around controlling social media usage because as we've spoken about, as a lot of you wrote in, that seems to be our main problem. Of course, they're designed to get you hooked. It is in the layout. It is in the architecture of social media apps of digital technology. But we can actually counteract the strategies that
让他们迷上我们，以逆转社交媒体的令人上瘾程度。我们可以看看他们是如何让我们参与进来的，并阻止或推回这些策略。以下是我们能做到这一点的一些方法。首先，只在你的笔记本电脑或台式电脑上使用社交媒体。这有助于限制在任何阶段拿出手机并不停地泡在应用程序上的持续诱惑。有一个地点、时间和位置可以让你访问
they're leveraging to keep us hooked to reverse how addictive social media is. We can look at how they are getting us engaged and prevent or push back against those strategies. Here are some of the ways that we can do that. Firstly, only use social media on your laptop or on your like desktop computer. This helps limit kind of the constant temptation to bring out your phone at any stage and like hook into the apps. There is a place and a time and a location where you can access. the information and the entertainment of social media, it's not that you're completely cutting yourself off,
社交媒体的信息和娱乐，并不是说你完全切断了自己，
but you are making it less accessible throughout the day. Secondly, set usage limits. And when you hit your usage limit and find yourself wanting to just brush past the alert, stop and ask why. What are you getting from going back on that app? Or is it just a lot of short-term gratification and a dopamine spike? Is it just because you're bored? And could you do something else instead? I would say go and download an app that feels more productive on your phone that you can go to as an alternative. I'm talking like a crossword app. I'm talking a newspaper app like the New York Times or the Atlantic or the Guardian so that when you are feeling compelled to get that nice gooey feeling from your phone, you're actually getting something useful out of that urge.
但你让它在一整天中不那么容易接触到。其次，设定使用限制。当你达到使用限制并发现自己只想无视提醒时，停下来问问为什么。你从重新打开那个应用程序中得到了什么？还是它只是一种长期的满足感和多巴胺的飙升？是不是只是因为你无聊？你本来可以做点别的吗？我想说去下载一个在手机上感觉更有生产力的应用程序，你可以把它作为替代品。我说的是填字游戏应用。我说的是像《纽约时报》、《大西洋月刊》或《卫报》这样的新闻应用，这样当你有强烈的冲动从手机中获得那种粘稠的感觉时，你实际上是从这种冲动中得到了有用的东西。
Also, turn off notifications, I've done this, it's incredible, my friends will tell you that I'm always on Do Not Disturb, which I'm sure pisses a few of them off because sometimes, yeah, it does take me a little while to reply, but I actually think that that is worth it because I get more done, because I'm not getting pulled into like the consumption vortex when I just wanted to reply to like a short message. Finally, use a grey scale over your apps. So there is a setting in your phone if you have an iPhone that is going to make all of the content grey, black and white so that the reward of seeing these bright colours and flashes of light and all of these things is less appealing. And you're still seeing the same content. You're still seeing the messages. You're still seeing
此外，关闭通知，我已经这样做了，这太不可思议了，我的朋友们会告诉你我一直开着勿扰模式，我确信这气到了他们中的一些人，因为有时，是的，我确实需要一点时间来回复，但我真的认为这是值得的，因为我完成了更多的事情，因为当我只想回复一条简短的消息时，我没有被卷入消费的漩涡。最后，在你的应用上使用灰度模式。因此，如果你的手机是 iPhone，里面有一个设置可以使所有的内容变成灰色、黑色和白色，这样看到这些明亮的颜色、闪光和所有这些东西的奖励就不那么吸引人了。而你仍然在看同样的内容。你仍然在看消息。你仍然在看
the reels, you're still seeing like the comments and all those things that you would go to social media for, but it's taken away the kind of color allure. And it's taken away like the gratification of seeing something bright that doesn't really exist in the real, like in the outside world that's going to keep you coming back for more. I think that that's everything that I have for you today, I'm realizing that this ended up being a significantly long episode. So on theme, if you had the attention span to make it all the way through, congratulations. I really hope that you enjoyed this episode. I will say, I'm also quite sick, and I probably should have addressed it at the beginning, but I have tonsillitis, which is, you know, maybe something that you can hear in this recording.
这些短视频，你仍然在看评论和所有那些你会为了社交媒体而去的东西，但它去除了那种色彩的吸引力。它也去除了看到明亮的东西的满足感，而这些东西在真实世界中并不真正存在，不会让你不断回头寻找更多。我想这就是我今天带给大家的全部内容，我意识到这最终成了一集相当长长的节目。所以应景的是，如果你有注意力坚持到最后，恭喜你。我真的希望你喜欢这一集。我要说的是，我也病得很重，我可能应该在一开始就提出来，但我得了扁桃体炎，你知道的，这也许是你在这段录音中能听到的声音。
So thank you for bearing with me as I am a little bit more nasally. I'm literally recording this in bed. So if you have made it this far, thank you. Make sure that you are following us on Spotify, Apple Podcasts, whatever you are listening right now. And if you can leave a five-star review, it would be greatly appreciated. It really helps the show to grow and reach new people. If you have anything else to say on this topic as well, as you probably heard, a lot of the insights did come from you, the listeners. So please feel free to DM me on Instagram. Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. I would love to hear from you. I would love to hear your thoughts, your opinions, your feelings. And as always, we will see you next week. Until then, stay safe,
所以谢谢你在我带着更多鼻音时对我保持耐心。我literally是在床上录音的。所以如果你坚持到了这一段，谢谢你。确保你在 Spotify、Apple Podcasts 或你现在正在收听的任何地方关注我们。如果你能留下五星好评，我们将不胜感激。它确实对节目的成长和接触新受众很有帮助。如果你对这个话题还有其他想说的，正如你可能听到的那样，很多见解确实来自于你们这些听众。所以请随时在 Instagram 上给我发私信。Instagram 账号是 That Psychology Podcast。我很想听到你的声音。我很想听听你的想法、你的意见、你的感受。和往常一样，我们下周见。在那之前，注意安全，
be kind, be gentle with yourself, and we will talk again soon. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. Eighty-four was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year.
善待他人，善待自己，我们很快就会再次交谈。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对我和说那是一个重大的时刻。八十四年对我来说意义重大。我是 Sam J.。我是 Alex English。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图弄清楚我们是如何与我们的朋友、同喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起度过难关的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代一样。84年是疯狂的一年。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere,
这是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 IHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《look back at it》。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？你们正在收听的是由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人 Kear Games 主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不太安全进行的坦诚对话，
but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hope.
但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着盔甲？它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这个能力并不意味着你需要这样做，在 AHA 广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《learn the hard way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一个骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped.
欧文斯女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的检测，对吧？我篡改过一次检测。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的大脑震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《情网》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在 IHeart Radio 应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理坚韧度、健康以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。经历一些困难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
收听《2%》。即 TWO percent，在 IHeart Radio 应用上。苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方。这是一个 IHeart 播客。保证真人。本期节目尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。